exploremos qué es la corriente eléctrica
y veamos cómo podemos calcularla así que
comencemos con la palabra corriente
corriente es una medida de cuánto fluye
alguna cosa por segundo vamos a
escribirlo es una medida de cuánto
alguna cosa puede ser cualquier cosa y
daremos ejemplos fluye por segundo por
ejemplo si tuviéramos que calcular
cuánta agua fluye por segundo en una
tubería en algún punto sería corriente
de agua si tuviéramos que calcular
cuánto aire por segundo fluye a través
de un túnel en algún momento eso sería
corriente de aire pero para la corriente
eléctrica calculamos cuánta carga fluye
por segundo cuánta carga fluye por
segundo digamos que a través de un cable
en cualquier punto así que veamos
algunos ejemplos imaginemos que tenemos
un cable metálico aquí y la especialidad
de los cables metálicos es que tienen
muchos electrones dentro de ellos que se
mueven libremente muchos electrones que
se mueven libremente y si empujamos
estos electrones entonces pueden fluir
y veremos en futuros vídeos cómo podemos
empujar los electrones pero una vez que
los electrones comienzan a fluir tenemos
una carga que fluye porque los
electrones son partículas cargadas de
modo que cuando los electrones fluyen
tenemos una corriente y ahora digamos
que nos detenemos en este punto y de
alguna manera calculamos la carga que
fluye a través de este punto digamos que
nos concentramos en este punto del cable
y calculamos cuánta carga fluye a través
de este punto la medimos y encontramos
que hay 10 kilos de carga 10 kilos de
carga en este punto en 5 segundos
entonces cuánta corriente hay en este
punto bueno generalmente representamos
la corriente con una y necesitamos
calcular cuánta carga fluye por segundo
es decir cuántos kilos fluyen por
segundo así que en este momento tenemos
10 colones por 5 segundos que equivalen
a 2 colas por segundo y ahora podemos
decir que la corriente en ese punto es
igual a 2 kilos por segundo lo que
significa que cada segundo pasan 2
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que tenemos
un cable diferente con una corriente
diferente y encontramos que tres colores
fluyen en 6 segundos puedes calcular la
corriente en este caso pausa el vídeo y
trata de resolverlo muy bien ahora la
corriente y que vamos a tener es igual a
3 colomos sobre 6 segundos y 3 dividido
entre 6 es igual a 1 sobre 2 entonces
obtenemos la mitad por lo que la
corriente en este punto es 0.5 coloms
por segundo y así es como calculamos la
corriente generalicemos esto vamos a ver
si podemos llegar a una fórmula general
para calcular la corriente en general
digamos que si tenemos una cantidad q de
carga que fluye en una cantidad de
segundos entonces podemos escribir que
la corriente en general va a ser la
cantidad de carga q dividida entre el
tiempo que esperamos dividido entre t y
si te fijas bien eso es lo que hicimos
en ambos casos dividimos la carga entre
el tiempo y en general así es como se
calcula
cliente por lo tanto la unidad de
corriente es coloms por segundo y los
colones por segundo a menudo se les
llama amperes o amperios que abrevia mos
con una mayúscula y llevan el nombre del
científico francés andré amper que hizo
mucho trabajo sobre electricidad así que
podríamos decir que esta corriente es
igual a 2 amperes amperes que equivalen
a colomos por segundo y aquí también
podríamos decir que esto es 0.5 amperes
haremos un ejemplo más para ser muy
claros con esto digamos que alguien
tiene una corriente de 3 am pers qué
significa eso muy bien significa que hay
tres problemas de carga que pasan cada
segundo ahora puedes calcular cuánta
carga pasa en 5 segundos de modo que si
espera 5 segundos cuenta carga habrá
pasado a través de ese punto pausa el
vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy bien ya
sabemos que pasan 3 con la oms cada
segundo como queremos calcular la
cantidad de carga que pasa simplemente
tenemos que multiplicar esto por 5
segundos
cancelamos segundos con segundos y
obtenemos 15 blums podrían haber usado
esta fórmula que es la misma fíjense
estamos multiplicando la corriente por
el tiempo así que si multiplicamos la
corriente por el tiempo obtenemos la
carga una última cosa de la que podemos
hablar es de la dirección de la
corriente eléctrica
digamos que todos los electrones que
tenemos aquí fluyen hacia la derecha y
te pregunto en qué dirección fluye la
corriente eléctrica y se puede decir
intuitivamente que a la derecha porque
todos los electrones fluyen hacia la
derecha pero resulta que es en la
dirección opuesta la dirección de la
corriente eléctrica que elegimos va en
dirección opuesta al flujo de electrones
y te estarás preguntando por qué la
razón principal de esto es porque los
electrones son partículas cargadas
negativamente fíjense cuando asignamos
la dirección de la corriente eléctrica
no teníamos idea de electrones y
protones eso fue mucho antes de
descubrirlo solo pensábamos que había
algún tipo de carga positiva que se
movía por
cable y eso es lo que nos daba la
corriente por eso elegimos la convención
para la corriente como la dirección del
flujo de cargas positivas y dado que los
electrones resultan ser partículas
cargadas negativamente no tenemos opción
tenemos que elegir la convención para
estar en la dirección opuesta del flujo
de electrones así que si el flujo es de
cargas positivas
la corriente estará en la misma
dirección si el flujo es de cargas
negativas
la corriente estará en dirección opuesta
debido a que los electrones son
partículas cargadas negativamente la
dirección que elegimos es opuesta
para resumir rápidamente lo que
aprendimos la corriente eléctrica es la
cantidad de carga que fluye por segundo
a través de cualquier cable en un punto
dado y vimos cómo calcular la corriente
eléctrica vimos sus unidades que son
colomos por segundo que también se les
llama apersonó amperios y finalmente
vimos que la dirección de la corriente
es la dirección en la que se mueve la
carga positiva ahora debido a que en
todos los cables metálicos los
electrones siempre se van a mover y los
electrones son partículas cargadas
negativamente casi en todos los
circuitos eléctricos y cables con los
que estaremos tratando la dirección de
la corriente siempre va a ser en la
dirección opuesta a la del flujo de
electrones